you've heard about North organization
how to set up your depth in 10 cents
human level performance as a proxy for
Bayes error and how to estimate your
avoidable bias and variance let's pull
it all together into a set of guidelines
to how to improve the performance of
your learning algorithm so I think
getting a supervised learning album to
work well means fundamentally hoping or
assuming that you can do two things
first is that you can fit the training
set pretty well and you can think of
this as roughly saying that you can
achieve low avoidable bias and the
second thing you're assuming you can do
well is that doing well in the training
set generalizes pretty well to the DEF
set or the test set and this is for
saying that variance is not too bad and
in the spirit of organization what you
see is that there's a certain set of
knobs you can use to fix avoidable bias
issues such as training bigger network
or training longer and there's a
separate set of things you can use to
address variance problems such as
regularization or getting more training
data so to summarize the process we've
seen the last several videos if you want
to improve the performance of your
machine learning system I would
recommend looking at the difference
between your training error and your
proxy for Bayes error and to teach a
sense of the avoidable bias in other
words just how much better do you think
you should be trying to do on your
training set and then look at the
difference in your def ever in your
training error as an estimate of how
much of a variance problem you have in
other words how much harder you should
be working to meet your performance
generalize from the training set to the
death set that it wasn't trained on
explicitly
you
so to whatever sense you
try to reduce avoidable buyers I would
try to apply tactics like train a bigger
model so you can just do better on your
training sets or pretty longer use a
better optimization algorithm such as
add momentum or rmsprop or use a better
algorithm like Adam or one other thing
you could try is to just find a better
neural network architecture or better
set of hyper parameters and this could
include everything from changing the
activation function to changing the
number of layers or hidden units
although if you do that it would be in
the direction of increasing the model
size to trying out other models or other
model architectures such as recurrent
neural networks and convolutional neural
networks which we'll see in later
courses whether or not a new neural
network architecture will fit your
training set vendor is sometimes hard to
tell in advance but sometimes you can
get much better results with a better
architecture next to the extent that you
find out variants is a problem some of
the menu of techniques you could try
then include the following you can try
to get more data because getting more
data to train on could help you
generalize better to death set data that
you have from didn't see you could try
regularization so this increasing by l2
regularization or dropout or data
augmentation we should talked about in
the previous course or once again you
can also try various neural network
architecture hybrid parameter search to
see if that can help you find a neural
net an architecture that is better
suited for your problem I think that
this notion of bias or voidable bias and
variance is one of those things that
easily learn but hard to master and
you're able to systematically apply the
concepts from this week's videos you
actually be much more efficient much
more
semantics and much more strategic than a
lot of machine learning teams in terms
of how to systematically go about
improving the performance of your
machine learning system so that this
week's homework to allow you to practice
and exercise more your understanding of
these concepts that says left with this
week's homework and then look forward to
also seeing you in next week's videos
you
Aran's is one of the